it's hard not to love the smell of the
holidays it's this incredible mix of
warm cookies - no red cups attacking the
sanctity of Christmas and of course
sales black Fridays now extended to
Black November because one day just
isn't enough starts as soon as Halloween
ends and it's designed to make us well
want more stuff over 135 million people
are expected to shop during Thanksgiving
weekend and shoppers are expected to
spend over three billion dollars on
Cyber Monday alone
the holiday season is key for many
retailers it generates as much as 30
percent of their annual sales so how do
retailers get us to spend our
hard-earned cash on stuff that we might
not even need first retailers create a
sense of urgency and scarcity inducing a
sort of FOMO panic yeah the fear of
missing out it applies to how we shop -
because Black Friday's premise is
actually pretty simple set a time limit
to drive up sales shoots and it works
last year the average shopper spends
about three hundred and eighty dollars
over the four-day Black Friday weekend
and thanks to us being constantly
plugged in retailers have 24/7 access to
us which makes sense when more and more
people are shopping online and on their
phones over 22 billion dollars was spent
online during November 2014 alone on
Thanksgiving Day last year more than
half of Internet traffic came from
mobile devices God's bless one-click
ordering consider all the offers
flooding Facebook Twitter Pinterest the
emails you're getting right now you know
the ones that say don't miss out on this
great deal or get this special free gift
last chance I get anxious just thinking
about what's in my inbox and those the
emails might seem really cheesy but they
actually work one in four orders made
online on Black Friday in 2014 was
because of those emails
let's say you decide to put on some
pants and don't shop in an actual store
how do the retailers drag you in with
door Busters the most heavily discounted
items in the store that is if that's all
you walk out with people will wait for
hours and hours to be the first in the
store so that they can grab that 50
percent off bargain or else they'll miss
out and yeah you will miss out because
that is how the sale is designed because
there are usually only a few units
available at any given store and when
they're gone they're gone
and here's retailers big Black Friday
secret it's not just a smart TV that
you're buying after all once you get the
TV you want to get the discounted Xbox
and once you get the Xbox you want the
two controllers because you want to play
with bait and Bay wants to play fallout
4 and Halo 5 o but for the TV
you're gonna need cables a wall mounting
kit installation but that's ok because
you just saved a lot of money on that TV
so you can afford to spend a little bit
more elsewhere right so yeah
Black Friday sales are definitely
helping retailers make money but are
they helping the rest of us save any